In this last video,
we illustrate
how to use the techniques
we have recently
learned in order to
answer some questions
about the following
classical problem--
consider a gambler
putting a bet of $1
in a game that has a pay off
of one dollar if she wins.
We assume that this
is a fair game,
so the probability of winning
$1 on each play of the game
is one-half.
And so the probability of
losing the bet is also one-half.
Suppose that she
starts with i dollars
and continues to play
the game until either she
reaches a goal of n dollars, or
she has no money left, whatever
comes first.
Let us consider a
first question, which
is the following-- what is the
probability that she ends up
with having her
goal of n dollars?
Now, how to go about
solving this problem?
Can we think of a Markov
chain representation
for this problem?
But in that case, what
would be good choices
for the definition
of the states?
Let us think.
At any point in time, the
only relevant information
is the amount of money
the gambler has available.
How she got to that amount
in the past is irrelevant.
And if this amount is
neither zero nor n,
then she will play again.
And the next state
will be a number
which will be increased
or decreased by one unit,
depending on winning
or losing the next bet.
So we can represent the
possible evolution of this game
with the following
probability transition graph.
So we have n plus 1 states.
This is the state where
she loses all her money.
she has i amount of money
before the next betting.
And here, this is the state
n where she reaches her goal
and she can leave.
In terms of the
transition probability,
assuming that you are at a
given time in that state,
that means that you have
i money in your pocket,
and you play the next bet.
With a probability one-half,
you will gain or win.
And so your amount
of money is i plus 1.
Or you lose and your
money is i minus 1.
And you keep repeating until
you reach either n or zero.
And then you stop.
So this is a Markov chain, and
that state 0 and that state n
are absorbing states.
Once you reach them,
you stay there forever.
So what this question is
asking is the probability a
of i of-- starting from i, what
is the probability that you
will end up in that
absorbing state?
And we have done this
calculation previously.
So let us repeat the
technique very briefly.
Clearly here, if you
start with 0 dollars,
you will never reach that.
So it's going to be 0.
On the other hand, if you
start with your desired goal,
you don't play anymore.
So your probability is 1.
Now of course,
what is of interest
is if i is strictly
between 0 and n.
And now the question is how
to calculate that probability.
And we have seen
that the way to do
that is to look
at the situation,
and say let's assume that
you are in that state i.
And what happens next?
Well with a probability 0.5,
you will move to that state.
And now you are in that level
with i plus 1 amount of money.
And what is the probability
that, given that you're here,
you're going to end up in n?
It's going to be a i plus one.
So it's a i plus one.
Plus the other
alternative is that you
are going to lose money
and end up in that state.
And there, the remaining
probability to reach the time n
is a i minus 1.
So you have this
kind of equation.
This is valid for all
i between 0 and n.
And this is a system of
equations that you can solve.
It's not very
difficult to solve.
Actually, you can
look in the textbook.
There will be some
trick to do that.
There are many, many
ways to do that.
We're not going to spend
our time going into details,
but essentially if
you solve that system,
you will see that the
answer will be that a of i
is i over n.
So if you start with
i amount of money,
the probability that you're
going to reach your goal here
is i over n.
So here clearly, if
you're extremely greedy,
and you have a very,
very, very high goal,
that means n is
very, very large--
so large that compared
to your initial amount i,
n can be considered
to be infinity.
Then the probability that you're
going to reach your high goal
will go to 0, where
n goes to infinity.
So again, if you are
extremely greedy,
no matter how much your fixed
amount of initial money is,
the probability that you
will stop the game reaching
your goal is going to
be increasingly small.
And since the other state
is 1 minus this one,
the priority that you're
going to get ruined
is going to be closer to 1.
All right, so we have
that answer here.
What about the next question?
Next question is
the following-- what
would be the expected
wealth at the end?
Again, this is a
Markov chain where
there are two absorbing states.
All the others are transient.
You're guaranteed
with probability 1
that you will reach
either 0 or n.
So it's a valid question to
know once you reach either 0
or n, what is the expected
wealth at the end?
Well, if you arrive
here, it's going to be 0.
And if you arrive here,
it's going to be n.
So the expected
value of that wealth
will be 0 times the probability
of ending in that, plus n times
the probability
of getting there.
So it's going to be that
expression-- 0 times
1 minus a of i,
plus n times a of i.
And here what we then get is
n times i over n, which is i.
Which is quite interesting.
This is exactly how you started.
So in some sense, in expectation
there is no free lunch here.
The next question is--
how long does the gambler
expect to stay in the game?
We know that eventually,
he will either reach 0
or n with probability 1.
The question is-- how
long is it going to take?
Again, we have seen
in a previous video
that this is essentially
calculating the expectation
to absorption.
And we know how to do that.
So let's recap what we had said.
If you define mu of i to be
the expected number of plays
starting from i,
what do you have?
Well, for i equal
to 0 or i equals n,
either way-- if you
start from here,
or you start from here--
the expected number of plays
is 0, right?
Because you're done.
And otherwise, you use the same
kind of derivation that we had.
If you start at i
between 1 and n,
then you will see that mu of i,
after one transition, plus 1,
you will either be in state
i plus 1-- in that case,
this expectation will
be mu i plus 1 --
or you will be in
state i minus 1.
In that case, the
expectation is mu i minus 1.
So this is an equation
that you have,
which is almost the
same as this one,
except that you
have a plus 1 in it.
And as we had discussed
before, in general
this is the kind of
formula that you have.
Now you can solve the system.
I will let you do that.
There are many ways to do this.
But the solution that
you're going to have
is that mu i will be equals
to i times n minus i.
This is the result.
Finally what would
be the case if you
didn't have a fair game-- for
example, unfair to the gambler
or unfair to the casino?
What we mean here is
that the probability p
is different from 0.5.
So here, instead of 0.5,
you have p everywhere.
And here, of course,
you have 1 minus p
everywhere on this side.
So you have a
probability p of winning,
and probability 1 minus
p of losing each bet.
So you might ask the
same question-- well,
for the probability a of
i, you still have 0 here.
You still have 1 here.
The formula that you
would write here,
instead of writing
it this way, it
would be-- you start from
here with a probability p.
You end up here.
And with a probability of 1
minus p, you end up there.
And the expression that
you get for a of i--
if you define r to be 1
minus p over p-- you will see
that a of i is going to be
1 minus r to the power of i
over 1 minus r to the power n.
And what would be the expected
amount of time she will play?
Instead of that equation,
if you solve it,
you would have mu of i
equals r plus 1 divided
by r minus 1 times i minus
n times 1 minus r to the i
divided by 1 minus
r to the power n.
Because you would have here
again p, and 1 minus p here.
And you can see that when p is
strictly less than one-half--
in other words, it's even
worse for this gambler--
then a of i-- which is
the probability of getting
to this favorable
state-- will also go to 0
when n goes to infinity.
And in the case where p is
strictly greater than 0.5--
that means that she has some
favored odd on her favor--
then in that case, this number r
to the power n will go to zero.
And 1 minus r of i will
represent the probability
that she would become
infinitely rich.
In other words, being very
greedy and n going to infinity.
This will go to 0 and 1
minus r to the power of i
is the probability that she
would get infinitely rich.